i'm gonna say i learned something
interesting today about the streaming
service hbo max
which has a lot of great content
including my conan without borders
travel specials
you know i have hbo but i i'm not sure
if i have hbo max
andy we've been over this a million
times if you have
hbo then you have hbo max and i was
surprised to learn hbo max already has
some streaming spin-offs that
look pretty interesting check them out
if you like hbo max you're going to love
these new hbo max streaming spin-offs
including hbo fax showing just the
scenes from 90s movies featuring fax
machines
hbo dax all of dax shepard's screen
career
plus home videos hacked from kristen
bell's phone
hbo acts streaming simply the best of
after hours lumberjack
porn hbo yaks a service for people who
love himalayan ranching
hbo slack's your place for content
featuring male characters dressed in
business casual
hbo capex just a loop of the kevin
spacey movie k-packs
hbo supermax solely security footage of
inmates working out in the yard at
supermax prisons
hb imax where you only get to see about
1 64th of the image
hb joe sax hundreds of hours of nfl
legend joe montana
failing to learn how to play the
saxophone and remember newspapers
remember the comics page remember a
comic strip called kathy
remember the third panel of that comic
strip then you'll love
hbo axe hb oh no a collection of over
200 jeffrey tube and zoom meetings
hbo o'reilly auto parts every o'reilly
auto parts commercial
ever aired hb
row a montage of all the moments scooby
realizes the gang's in trouble
and sam obh all of hbo max's content
played backwards yes that's hbo fax dax
axe axe yaks slacks imacs k-packs joe
sachs super max
oh no uh oh rutro and zam ovh
brought to you by hbo max
so wait a minute andy let me get this
straight you don't know about hbo max
but you did the voice over for their
commercial
i my one of my techniques is to do all
my voice over work in a fugue state
so i don't remember any of it you don't
remember any of it i don't remember any
of it no i threw a series of sensory
deprivation tanks and
medication all right i am blackout drunk
okay you were drunk when you did that
yeah nice to know